All right.
Thank you for coming, and good afternoon.
And thanks for coming to this mini
symposium. The title is very broad, "Cutting-Edge
Advances in Hematology."
So I would say over the past
decade, and in particular during the past year, we have
seen significant progress in this whole field,
and now we see hematology is
evolving from a very phenotypic
definition now to a truer systems
level and holistic understanding of the mechanism and
becoming actionable, and so discipline.
And
so you're going to see a couple of highlights today from the talks we
selected, but also I want to give a little bit of my own
viewpoint on what happened during the past year or two
in the field of hematology.
So I think
several major advances have been
truly demonstrated and started to shape the field,
reshaping the field. And first, I think in the single-cell and spatial omics,
and now have it represented in the symposium today, but kind of
broadly implicating almost whatever
cancer research, and you get a much
finer-scale understanding of disease mechanism.
And as far as I can recall, for example, the Human
Bone Marrow
Cell Atlas and the bone marrow microenvironment, and the
lymphoma
microenvironment dissected in a spatial resolution
and a single-cell resolution, I think it published last year by Mark
Green's lab, I think, in cancer cells that started to reshape the
whole field of hematology as well.
So second, and I think functional
genomics and CRISPR screen,
and
they started to get in vivo and understand how you can perturb
a hematopoietic system, and to understand how
does that change the trajectory of other diseases,
including hematological, but also solid cancers as
well. I think
really bringing that functional genomics tool
into the renewed understanding of the disease
mechanism in the whole field.
All right.
So now number three, you're going to see a couple of highlights in
this mini symposium today.
Immunotherapy continues to be a major
cornerstone in the treatment of hematologic malignancies,
and also immunotherapy, including
CAR T,
continues to evolve. And we have
further refined and a renewed understanding of the mechanism, not just
in how to engineer, how to manufacture CAR T cells, but also in the
mechanism in understanding their functional state.
You're going to hear something about that today, and also understand
how patients develop resistance to
immunotherapy. So finally,
so not heavily represented in our symposium today, but I
do feel the emergence of
AI digital pathology and all the computational tools
plus the AI-driven approach are
starting to change how we--
so research, number one. Number two, also potentially change
the clinical practice as in clinical pathology.
So today, a couple of talks,
seven speakers
selected by the committee to represent
the most interesting cutting-edge advances in the
very broad field of hematology. And so I don't want to go over
one by one. Instead, I want to highlight some kind of unified
themes that are together tackling in
a hematology space. Number one, I think the therapeutic
and metabolic states, and
so now we see the hematology or hematologic
cancer is not just driven by genomic alterations and also
transcriptional states, but
functional, in particular metabolism, plays a very critical role.
Can you target that to change the microenvironment?
Can you target that to change their cell state such that they can expose
their vulnerability and to gain better therapeutic outcome?
So second, as I alluded, I think in the immunotherapy, including CAR
T, it's not just, okay, how can we make a better CAR and
really understand what's going on
in the different CAR states, both during
manufacturing and post-infusion, I think how the different CAR T
cell functional states and the microenvironment
can
change the therapeutic outcome in both clinical model and also in the
human clinical trials you're going to hear about today.
So number three, the mechanism
in hematologic cancer and they're largely driven by
genomic alterations, including
new mutations and
structural variants,
but it's increasingly recognized.
I think this evolutionary process might be
driven by epigenetic mechanism as well.
You're going to hear some exciting work today about
epigenetics and also how to target the epigenetic,
including the
post-transcriptional gene regulation as a new
approach or a new avenue
to understand the mechanism of hematological disease, but also
how to better treat them.
So finally,
I think now we gain more insights into the
disease biology,
in particular, the hematological hematopoietic function,
including somekind of novel
regulators never described in this context, such as
SMAD12L in the platelet
dysfunction. Again, here, those kind of basic
research that can provide
new insights into the understanding of hematological disease
mechanism. So I'm going to just stop here and
really introduce our first speaker.
And
so I think you can come to the stage.
And our first speaker,
Michelle Haber
from Sydney in Australia.
Thanks very much for the opportunity to present my work on behalf of our
team on
potentiating venetoclax response using the NAMPT inhibitor
OT-82. I have
no financial relationships to disclose.
So as you would all be very aware, acute myeloid leukemia, or AML,
is still a highly lethal disease in both children and
adults, with the median five-year survival being less than
30% in adults. And in children with this disease, a third of
them relapse, and the majority of those children will die of their
disease. So a significant advance forward in this field, again,
as many of you would know, would be the approval of venetoclax combined
with azacitidine for adult AML that increased
remission times, sped up the time to remission, and increased
overall survival. But durable responses
are rare because of the
resistance to venetoclax, and in children with AML, the efficacy of
venetoclax is yet to be established.
And so resistance to venetoclax via a variety of
characterized mechanisms, whether it's apoptotic rewiring or metabolic
reprogramming, is a major issue,
and novel strategies are required to overcome that if we're going to improve
outcomes in this disease.
So there was a landmark paper about five years ago from Craig Jordan's
group, which demonstrated that a hallmark of relapsed
venetoclax-resistant leukemic cells was increased
dependence on nicotinamide NAD metabolism,
driven by NAMPT, the rate-limiting
enzyme in
NAD biosynthesis. And
what he showed was that as you go from
diagnosis with AML to refractory AML, not
only does venetoclax azacitidine resistance increase,
but so does nicotinamide metabolism and so does
sensitivity to inhibitors of NAMPT.
So that suggested that elevated NAMPT activity
may not only be a mechanism of resistance, but a potential
metabolic vulnerability in AML.
So this is just to remind you of the importance of NAD in
metabolism. It's critical for energy metabolism,
for ATP production, both through the
glycolytic and OXPHOS pathways, and it's also
critically important for DNA repair, for cell signaling,
for immune functioning, for inflammation through these
various mediators. So the aim of this study was to
address the question of, "Can the altered dependency of
relapsed/refractory AML leukemic stem cells on
nicotinamide metabolism be therapeutically
exploited to potentiate venetoclax response in
AML models?"
Our group published, in 2020, two back-to-back
papers that describe the development of the
novel NAMPT inhibitor OT-82, which we showed at
the time was extremely
effective in terms of its anti-leukemic effect on
pediatric ALL patient-derived xenograft models.
You can see here 21 models that we tested,
including some of the worst prognosis subtypes.
And in those 21, 17 out of 21 either had
a complete response or a maintained complete response
by the stringent Objective Response Measure,
ORM, criteria. And importantly, we
demonstrated selective toxicity of OT-82 for the
leukemic cells by comparison with the normal bone marrow cells.
So we were very keen to try this out in AML, and
here what you're looking at is the primary
AML cells from 10 adult AMLs, and what we were looking at there was
the LC50 of OT-82 by
comparison with a range of other drugs or drug combinations
that are used to treat AML. And you can see that
OT-82
consistently had the lowest LC50s by comparison
with all the other drugs. And in blue, you can see the normal bone marrow
cells from some of these patients, and you can see quite a wide therapeutic
window because this
was not cytotoxic to these cells at concentrations that were
lethal to the AML cells.
So then to explore the genomic context of response, here you
can see these were all genomically annotated
AMLs, and they included some of the worst subtypes, including
P53 mutated
and
FLT3 mutated. You can see in almost all of these,
we've got our LC50s for OT-82 in the
nanomolar or subnanomolar ranges, and that
includes almost every single one of the highly
venetoclax-resistant
patient samples.We then wanted to test this drug in
vivo, so we started off with pediatric
AML PDXs. The first one is PRR485.
This and AML49 are both highly
resistant to venetoclax. They're both very high risk.
They're KMT2A or mil rearranged. And you can
see on the left side for PRR485, that
OT-82 in the blue significantly
extended event-free survival by comparison with the
control in black, but also there you've got cytarabine and
daunorubicin standard of care, and a significant increase in
EFS over that. But on the right-hand side of the figure, you
can see that the real extension
in event-free survival came from the combination of either venetoclax
OT-82 or venetoclax OT-82 in
combination with azacitidine, and the azacitidine added
nothing to the combination of OT-82 and venetoclax.
So we dropped the azacitidine, and we trialed that in
AML49, which in addition had K-RAS and
HSPC90 mutations, very venetoclax resistant.
And you can see that the combination of venetoclax and OT-82
leads to really remarkable extension of survival.
So we then moved to a single mouse trial.
This was 16 AML PDXs, seven
pediatric and nine adult, and they reflect the
heterogeneity and adverse biology of AML,
as you can see across the bottom. And we tested them against either vehicle,
OT-82, venetoclax, or the combination.
And what you can see on the right-hand side is that in this entire pooled
cohort that OT-82 had
substantially increased event-free survival over vehicle,
whereas venetoclax did not.
But it was really the combination of venetoclax and OT-82
that led to the most robust and durable responses in
these models.
If we then separate them into the pediatric and the adult models, you can
see that in both groups, OT-82 in blue
led to a significantly increased event-free survival by
comparison with the control, whereas venetoclax was not
significantly different from control.
And in the pediatric PDXs, the combination of
venetoclax and OT-82 was significantly better than
OT-82 alone. In the adults, there was a trend
towards that, but it didn't achieve significance, and you can see that reflected
also in the
ORM bar graphs here, where you see almost no
responses with venetoclax alone.
You see complete remissions in the OT-82,
but it's not until you get to the combination of venetoclax and OT-82 that you
see the maintained complete responses.
And then finally here, in this graph here, what we're
looking at is--
We were looking for molecular correlates of response.
So we took
all of the PDXs and divided them into those
which were responders, which is shown in the dark green in the left-hand panel,
and the non-responders, which are in red.
And the first thing that you'll note is that the vast majority of all
of these, with some of the, as I said, with the most adverse
biology, almost all of these nevertheless were
responsive to
OT-82. There were three PDXs across the cohort
that were not responsive. You can see them in red over
there. And interestingly, in each case, they were also
resistant to venetoclax. But in every case, if you
go to the third column, you can see in green that the
combination of OT-82 and venetoclax
led to a substantially increased response
over what was seen with venetoclax only.
With this small number of PDXs, we were not able to
identify any particular subtypes that were
particularly responsive or unresponsive.
There were no statistically significant correlations.
But just a couple of interesting observations, that if you look
at the pediatric PDXs that were
resistant to venetoclax, four out of five of them
were actually
KMT2A
rearranged, and all of them were
subsequently responsive to either OT-82 alone or
OT-82 in combination with venetoclax.
Similarly, if you look at the seven PDXs across
the adult and pediatric that were FLT3 mutated,
again, one of the most adverse biology, for every one of those,
if you look back, you can see that there was a good
response either to OT-82 alone or OT-82
in combination with venetoclax. So,
in summary,
I hope I've convinced you that OT-82 can potentiate
venetoclax in severely venetoclax-resistant AML, both
in vitro and in vivo, and in both pediatric and adult
disease. I think we're going to need ongoing single mouse
trial-guided molecular profiling studies to
elucidate predictive biomarkers of response.
But I think what's striking was the efficacy of OT-82-based
therapy across all of these genomically diverse and adverse
disease subtypes. And finally, these findings, I think,
support OT-82 plus venetoclax as a novel
metabolism combination therapy in both adult and pediatric
AML that has the potential to overcome resistance
and to improve outcomes for our small and large
AML patients, particularly those with venetoclax-resistant
disease. And I'd like to finish just by acknowledging the
team who actually conducted this work and
our collaborators, and also our funding
agencies.
And the panel is open for questions.
Hi. Yeah, really exciting data. I'm glad to see somebody's following up on
Courtney's work with the nicotinamide story.
What was your treatment protocol for the mice for your venetoclax and your
OT-82 for the in vivo treatment?
For the OT-82, the three days on, four days off schedule.
And then for venetoclax?
Ugh.
I can't remember. I'll tell you that as soon as I finish the talk.
Okay. Yeah.
Sorry. Apologies.
That's fine. And for how long did you give it?
That was given for four weeks.
Four weeks.
I believe. Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Yeah. Thank you very much.
Great.
Hi, thank you for a lovely talk. Hector Keown from Imperial College London.
We've been looking at NAMPT inhibitors in a different setting, in
ovarian. We're looking at combination with PARP inhibitors, and we've seen some
evidence there that K-RAS and PI3 kinase mutations actually sensitize that
combination. I know it's very early days, but do you have any
inkling as to which mutations might be relevant, and is there an overlap with the
venetoclax-resistant mutations?
We don't yet know the answer to that.
That's something that we definitely want to be characterizing and looking into
further. I'm sorry I don't have the answer to that.
That's okay. And just very quickly, you've gone with this new
compound. Is there any specific advantage over some of the
older NAMPT inhibitors like AZD6731?
Yeah. We think there's a number of advantages.
We think, first of all, it's pharmacologically superior.
The older NAMPT inhibitors had retinal toxicity as one of
their major challenges. This one does not, either in the preclinical models or in
the patients that were treated in the clinic.
We think certainly, as we're getting a better handle of what are the better
indications
for these NAMPT inhibitors, then instead of just
giving them to all the patients, we'll be able to work it out.
I think it's very important given that the
DLT for OT-82 and for many
other of these NAMPT inhibitors is thrombocytopenia.
I think that we need to be using clinical protocols that have
mitigation of thrombocytopenia as part of their clinical
care. And I think also it's
going to be the combinations of these NAMPT inhibitors with drugs where we can
reduce the levels in a really tight trade, how to give them in a way that get
the greatest therapeutic benefit is going to allow us to move this forward in the
clinic in a way that this has stalled until now.
But I think it's got a bright future, actually.
Yeah. Wonderful. Thank you.
Hi, I'm Greg from Remedy Plan Therapeutics.
We have a NAMPT inhibitor in clinical studies right now.
We actually just started a AML MDS clinical study with a novel
NAMPT inhibitor that doesn't have thrombocytopenia.
We're really excited about this work.
Congratulations, and we'd love to follow up with you.
Great. Thank you.
All right.
I think we have very good Q&A session. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Michelle.
Okay. I'm going to introduce our second speaker, Dr.
Kai Wu from Fred Hutch Cancer Center,
and he's going to talk about non-canonic CAR T cell
states.
Yeah. First, thanks to the committee and the chair for
the opportunity to present. And good afternoon, everyone.
It's really a great honor to
share our latest findings in anti-BCMA CAR T against
multiple myeloma.
So first, I don't have any COI to disclose.
And a little bit background about multiple myeloma.
So multiple myeloma is a highly prevalent and lethal
hematomalignancy derived from plasma cell in bone
marrow.
So it's a really hard to treat disease.
It's causing over 12,000 deaths annually in the
States. And
recently, the anti-BCMA CAR T therapy has exhibited unprecedented
efficacy against multiple myeloma,
and
this efficacy has led to FDA approval of two BCMA CAR
T products. And first is ide-cel, the other one is
ciltacel.
But despite this efficacy,
anti-BCMA CAR T therapy is still suffering from certain limitations.
The first one is, so most of the patients, they still relapse.
And also for some patients, especially the ones who received
earlier CAR T products, including ide-cel and orva-cel.
So these patients can relapse quite rapidly, even after a pretty
deep initial response with MRD negativity.
And unlike other CD19 positive malignancy,
in multiple myeloma, antigen escape is not a
major
mechanism leading to relapse. So actually for many
patients, when they relapse, the cancer cell, they are still expressing
BCMA.
So in this study, we are trying to figure out what
are the molecular and the cellular mechanisms that are
associated with either response or resistance to BCMA
CAR T therapy.
To address these questions, so we designed this study.
So basically, we collected PBMC and bone marrow samples
from
22 multiple myeloma patients who received four
different types of CAR T therapy. So
all these four CAR T therapies, they are all anti-BCMA CAR T, and they are
all 4-1BB ζ CAR.
And also, when we have those samples,
actually we collected their pre-infusion baseline samples and
also their serial post-infusion time points.
And then we did a flow sorting. We sorted for CD3 positive
compartment, and also we sorted for the CD3 negative and CD19
negative compartment. And then we profiled them using single-cell
multi-omics technology.And in this
study, we also have five age-matched housing control.
So those are the donors that underwent total hip
replacement surgery.
So for the patients, we first stratify them
into different groups based on their PFS, basically a
progression-free survival.
So for the patients who relapsed within a year,
we put them in the transient responder or TR group.
And for those patients who relapsed after a year, we put them in a durable
responder or DR group. And here, I'm showing the
FLC levels of the patients. So you can
see for the
TR patients, their FLC levels start to come back at
six months and then at a year, so it's quite high.
But for DR patients, their levels are dropped, and they remain at a relatively
low level
till a year. So these results further validated our
grouping strategy.
And next, let's focus on the CD3 positive compartment.
So after rigorous QC filtering,
here we ended up with over 800,000 good quality
single T cells. And using the canonical
markers, actually we annotated 17 different
T cell subsets or states.
And next, we used our
in-house developed
targeted amplification strategy to annotate CAR T cells.
So here we are
able to annotate over 40,000 CAR T cells,
and here they're highlighted in the U map.
Okay, so next let's focus on the CAR T cell states in the
early time points. That's within one month
post-infusion. So here we've found for the CAR T
cells from durable responders, actually they're
significantly enriched for the proliferating and
also early memory phenotype. And also
we calculated a exhaustion score for each single
cell for all the patients. And we saw for
the TR or the transient responder patients, so actually their
CAR T cells are showing a higher exhaustion
signature. And this difference is significant in the CD8
positive compartment.
And next, so let's look at the later time points.
And so that's three months and later after
post-infusion. So first we noticed that for
durable responders,
actually they have significantly more persisting CAR
T cells at later time points.
And also similarly, if we look at their exhaustion signature,
we're basically seeing the same pattern.
So like the TR patients,
their CAR T cells are showing a higher level of exhaustion
signature and the difference is more pronounced in the CD8 positive
compartment.
And another interesting finding is that at later time
points, we noticed that the CAR T cells from
durable responders, actually they are enriched for a very
unique cell state, and we call it T persistor.
So actually when we try to annotate this cell state, we had
some trouble, because when we take a closer look at their
signature, we found, oh wow, so actually their signature
genes are quite distinct from the canonical cell states.
So they're highly expressing AP1 genes, including
JunB, FosB, and also they're highly expressing
NF kappa B genes. And also they're highly expressing effector
cytokines,
including IFN-gamma, TNF alpha, and very high level of interleukin
2. And also they're highly expressing the bone marrow
residence genes, including CXCR4 and the CD69.
And also interestingly, we've found for this population, so
actually they have a relatively low level of exhaustion-related markers.
So this is really
surprising considering many of these CAR T cells, they have been staying in the
patients for over six months. But this finding is also
consistent with the high expression level of AP1 genes
because the overexpression of c-Jun
is able to
induce resistance to
exhaustion in CAR T cells. This has already been well-established.
And next, so we leveraged our paired single cell TCR
sequencing data. So basically in this part, we use a TCR
on the CAR T cells, and we use them as a marker to track
their clonal evolution over the treatment course.
So here, from this analysis, we've found actually the
CAR T persistors, they
actually arise from multiple different states at early
stage. Most of them including the T
effectors and proliferating T. And notably, the
CD4, some CAR4 compartment can also
contribute to the T persistor population at later stage. Yeah.
And next question we are asking is how CAR T cells
interact and impact the tumor microenvironment in patients.
And for these patients, since they are multimyeloma patients, the
TME is basically their bone marrow.
So here we basically map the non-B,
non-T cells from the bone marrow, and we
cluster them here. And we can see, so actually
the classic monocytes actually accounted for a big
portion of this population. And for the classic monocytes,
we calculated their immunosuppressive score for each cell
and for all the patients. And what we found is that for
the TR and DR patients, so at the baseline or
before CAR T treatment, they are showing similarly high level of
immunosuppression signatureBut after CAR T
infusion, we noticed that there is a dramatic
drop of their immunosuppressive signature in the TR patients who
received the pseudocell over the treatment course.
And next, we focus on the endogenous T cells from the
bone marrow.
So we noticed that
for the T factor cells, they expanded after the
CAR T infusion in both TR, basically transient responders and durable
responders.
And if we look at their TCR, so actually we found for
the DR,
durable responders, actually their endogenous T cells, they are showing
a elevated level of TCR diversity
actually as evidenced by the lower level of Gini
index in both CD4 and the CD8 compartment
at early time points. And also if you look at the
exhaustion score for endogenous T cells, actually we're also seeing a very
similar pattern.
So, in TR patients, their
endogenous T cells, they are showing a significantly
elevated exhaustion signature,
that this time they're significant in both CD4 and the CD8 compartment,
and also they are significant at both early time
points and later time points.
Okay, here are my conclusions. So, in this study,
we have identified some features of CAR T cells that
are associated with more durable therapeutic responses to
BCMA-targeted CAR T therapy against multiple myeloma.
And also in this study, we have also identified that
the BCMA CAR Ts from durable responders, actually they can
transition to a non-canonical persister
state from multiple cell states in
later time points.
And also we have found that effective CAR T therapy, they can also
impact the TME in a positive way.
And this is a highly collaborative project.
And here I would like to take this chance to acknowledge all the people
who have contributed to this project.
So first I would like to thank my mentor, Dr.
Lawrence Fong, he's here today, for all his guidance and
support for the project, and also all my colleagues who has
contributed to different sections of this study.
And also our clinical collaborators from both UCSF
and Fred Hutch, and also our collaborators
from O'Lab, AcumLab, CIP from UCSF.
And thanks to the patients and their families, and also the funding
sources. And I'll wrap up here, and
thanks for your attention. I'm ready for questions. Thanks.
Okay.
Thank you for the nice lecture. So the persistent T
cell is the... I mean, to know what population only shown
in the CAR T cell or the endogenous T cell does
also have the persistent T cell. And second question is that the
persistent T cell shows the unique pictures, so
I wonder whether you guys know that the master regulator, the
upstream transcription factor which affects the differentiation of
the persistent T cell.
Yeah. Great. Fantastic questions.
So for the first question, so since we're doing single-cell sequencing,
so the clustering is nothing is absolute,
but we see T persisters in endogenous T cell
at around 1%.
But in CAR Ts, the fraction is basically
from 20%, 30%, especially at later stage.
So I think this is probably more of a
unique or a CAR T enriched state.
Right. And, so, oh, sorry, for a second question?
The master transcription factor which affects the differentiation.
Yeah. Thanks. So, actually when we run a GSEA
analysis for the T persister, we found that the
4-1BB CAR score is pretty high. So
actually we generate that score from a cell analysis previous work.
So I think potentially this state
is induced by probably a continuous activation from the
CAR signaling that lead to this
cell state.
Okay. Got it.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you for the great talk. So I'm wondering also something about the cell
exhaustion and it shows at three months that durable
have less exhaustion marker than the
transient. So do we expect
the CAR T still be active at three months?
And because maybe the CAR T will be mainly
activated during the first seven days, even the first month, but we expect
the CAR T activity can decrease and persistent
CAR T activity can induce the CRS and neurotoxicity.
Yeah. I think this is a very good question.
So,
I would say so like the best experiments that probably we can
take some cells at late time point is do a probably a co-culture with
cancer cells, right? So this is a experiment that actually our to-do list.
But for now, so based on their signature for the T persisters, I think first of
all they are showing low level of exhaustion markers, and also they're
showing a high level of effector cytokine level.
So we think probably they should be functional.
But also, on the other hand, so like their cytotoxic
genes levels are relevant low. So we were thinking
when they function, so probably they're
functioning by probably providing more cytokines, probably less
cytotoxic. So that's what we
generate based on the hints from the signature.
But I think, probably experiment with cells from the patients at
late time will answer that question. Yeah.
Thank you. So the persistent population, it shows have
more AP-1 signature?
Yes.
And which means it has more exhaustion?
No, AP1 genes are basically the Jun, Fos,
JunB, FosB, those genes. Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you. And the last question is that you see the durable have
more diverse than the transient?
For endogenous T cells, yes. So I think this potentially indicate
a epitope spreading after
effective CAR T therapy. Yeah.
I see. Thank you.
Yeah, thanks.
All right, so given the time constraint, one quick question.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Could you just remind us, what was the
timeframe? So when you say persisting, what was the latest
sample that showed this phenotype?
So the latest sample we have is 360 days.
But, I think for the majority of them, we have three months and six months.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right. Let's thank the speaker again.
All right, I would like to introduce next speaker, Meredith Nix,
from Stanford University, and she's going to talk about new therapeutic
idea using molecular glue.
Hi, thank you so much for the opportunity to present my work today on a molecular
glue that harnesses lysine acetyltransferases to induce cell
death in lymphoma.
And I have no financial relationships to disclose.
The focus of my talk today is on using small molecules to target and
rewire cancer drivers. And small molecules fall into two
mechanistic categories. The first is occupancy driven
pharmacology, in which small molecules bind to a pocket on a protein,
thereby inhibiting function.
The second category is event-driven pharmacology, in which small
molecules induce protein-protein interactions, the most common
example of this being the recruitment of E3 ubiquitin ligases
to mark a protein of interest for degradation.
I'm going to specifically be talking about the cancer driver BCL6,
which is deregulated in diffuse large B-cell lymphoma and becomes
oncogenic.
And its interactions with co-repressors mediates the
repression of cell death pathways like P53 and Noxa
that would normally tell the cancer cell to die.
BCL6 is overexpressed in 40% to 60% of diffuse
large B-cell lymphomas, which comprise around 35% of all
non-Hodgkin's lymphomas, and this makes it a very desirable
therapeutic. And as such, many groups have worked on developing
loss-of-function small modalities targeting BCL6,
including inhibitors that bind to the BTB domain, disrupting the
interactions with co-repressors, as well as BCL6
degraders that eliminate the protein entirely.
However, these strategies have shown variable efficacy in
preclinical models. And so today, I'm alternatively going to be
talking about a gain-of-function strategy that harnesses
BCL6 to kill lymphomas.
And specifically, I'm going to be talking about a small molecule modality called a
transcriptional epigenetic chemical inducer of
proximity, which is a type of small molecule developed by the Gray and
Krapchy Labs at Stanford University that recruits a transcriptional
activator to cell death repressors such as BCL6, turning
on the downstream transcription of cell death pathways and turning a
transcriptional repression event into one of transcriptional activation.
Our labs have demonstrated that TCIPS recruiting BRD4 and
CDK9 can lead to very potent and selective cell killing.
In this work, we wanted to move beyond rewiring elongation
factors to rewiring chromatin modifiers for therapeutic
effects in lymphoma, and therefore, we focused on the paralog
lysine acetyltransferases P300 and CBP, which are
associated with active transcription and enhancers.
And they have a bromodomain that recognizes acetylated lysines, as well as a
lysine acetyltransferase domain that catalyzes acetylation of
histones and transcription factors.
We hypothesized that we could develop lysine acetyltransferase-based TCIPS,
or KatTCIPS, that recruit P300 and CBP to BCL6
loci to drive potent cell killing of lymphoma.
I first went about designing and developing these bivalent molecules,
selecting the BCL6 BTB domain inhibitor BI-3812,
and the P300 CBP selective bromodomain inhibitor
GNE-781, and used standard medicinal chemistry
to link the two binders together.
Ultimately, I'll be focusing today on our lead compound, TCIP3, which contains
a rigid piperazine linker.
I also synthesized negative controls that ablate binding to either of
the two proteins, but that maintain the same physicochemical properties as
TCIP3.
We were ultimately able to solve an X-ray co-crystal structure of a
KatTCIP in complex with BCL6 and P300.
You can see a BCL6 homodimer in the center, which each monomer
binding to one KatTCIP molecule and one P300
bromodomain. One thing that surprised us was the limited
plasticity of ligand binding, as well as the quite small
protein-protein interface. In fact, we only observed two neo
hydrogen bonds forming. And so we asked the question, is this
protein-protein interface sufficient to drive cooperative ternary
complex assembly? And so we used isothermal calorimetry to measure
binary and ternary KDs, which ultimately show that
TCIP3 is able to facilitate the cooperative assembly of
ternary complexes and is therefore a molecular glue, which may confer
beneficial properties in cells.
We've moved on to assessing the ability of TCIP3 to activate
BCL6-dependent transcription in a high BCL6
cell line, Karpas 422, using a GFP reporter assay.
And we were able to see potent
expression of GFP, as well as a hook effect, which is when high
concentrations of a bivalent molecule saturate individual binding
proteins and lead to reduced observable activity.We
then assessed the anti-proliferative abilities of these compounds in
the high BCL6 line, SU DHQ five. And you can
see that compared to the parental inhibitors, negative controls, and
various p300 Cbp modulators, tSIP3 was the
most potent, demonstrating an IC50 of
0.8 nanomolars in cells. And it also
outperformed the BCL6 degrader from Arvinas,
highlighting some of the potential benefits of gain-of-function strategies over
loss-of-function ones.
We also found that tSIP3 induced apoptosis over the course of
72 hours, and we confirmed that this potency was
dependent on the formation of a ternary complex as we dosed
one nanomolar of tSIP3 and then were able to rescue viability
by titrating and increasing concentrations of the BCL6
BTP domain inhibitors, as well as GNE-781.
We assessed the anti-proliferative effects of these compounds
across a panel of lymphoma and leukemia cell lines with varying
BCL6 expression, and we saw that six lymphoma lines with the
highest BCL6 expression were the most sensitive, indicating a
BCL6-dependent pharmacology.
p300 and Cbp are frequently mutated across hematological
malignancies, and so we therefore asked whether
tSIP3 potency depended on functional p300 and Cbp
alleles.
And we were surprised to find that two of the cells with high BCL6
expression that
were sensitive to tSIP3 only contained one or three
functional alleles, which suggested a fractional occupancy.
And this highlights a key distinction between loss-of-function modalities,
which must act at a full target occupancy in order to have
therapeutic effects, and gain-of-function ones, which only require
fractional occupancy to be potent.
And this can allow lower doses of drug concentration and the
avoidance of on-target toxicity.
Moving on, we assessed what the molecular consequences of ternary
complexes in cells would be. We performed p300 ChIP
sequencing, where we saw an enrichment of p300 at
BCL6 loci. We then asked if this
localization may result in localized
acetylation and performed ChIP sequencing of
H3K27 acetylation, a mark of active transcription,
and H2BK20 acetylation, which is a Cbp p300
specific marker.
And what we saw is that at sites that increase in acetylation, there
was an enrichment for published BCL6 binding sites in
human B cells and blood cancer cell lines.
We also saw a significant acetylation of the BCL6 protein
itself, which is consistent with reports that
p300 is capable of acetylating the RD two domain of
BCL6, which may contribute to de-repression of cell death pathways.
Importantly, we did not see global losses of acetylation, suggesting
tSIP3 is not a global HAT inhibitor or degrader.
Finally, we performed global RNA sequencing and proteomics,
which showed a gain of BCL6 target genes involved in cell cycle
arrest and killing, such as p27 and ARID3B,
and a loss of genes associated with DLBCL-specific super
enhancers, which was a bit surprising considering that we didn't see losses
of p300 occupancy at these regions and may reflect a
sensitivity of enhancers to small changes in coactivator
concentrations.
Overall, these data point to a model in which tSIP3
recruits a fraction of available p300 and Cbp to BCL6
loci, inducing localized acetylation of chromatin and
BCL6 itself, ultimately driving the transcription of
BCL6-dependent death pathways.
Finally, we assessed the in vivo efficacy of tSIP3, and were
fortunate to collaborate with Michael Green's lab at MD Anderson, who
immunized mice with sheep red blood to stimulate a germinal center
reaction and then assessed the ability of tSIP3 to ablate the
germinal center B cells, which are highly enriched for BCL6 and
serve as a model of lymphomas of germinal center origin.
And they saw a significant and dose-dependent
depletion of these germinal center B cells upon
tSIP3 treatment with a five mg per kg, twice-a-day
dosing intraperitoneally, nearly eliminating this population of
cells.
Notably, we saw that weight and B-cell percentages
remained constant over the course of the study, which is in contrast to
BCL6 homozygous knockout mice, of which 50% die
prematurely due to hyperinflammation, which highlights a key
difference between gain-of-function and loss-of-function modalities in terms of
potential safety profiles.
Finally, we assessed the efficacy of tSIP3 in a
CDX DLBCL tumor model and saw that tSIP3
rapidly shrank tumors.
At 11 days, you could barely detect any tumors, highlighting the therapeutic
potential of this modality.
In conclusion, we developed tSIP3, which is a molecular glue that potently
kills DLBCL cells by activating BCL6
regulated pathways. It recruits p300 and Cbp
activity to BCL6 loci and proximal chromatin, and it
demonstrates in vivo efficacy and is non-toxic.
And hopefully, you take away from this talk that we can harness lysines
acetyltransferases for gain-of-function therapeutic effects in
cancer. And with that, I'd like to thank all members of the Gray
Lab, the Crabtree lab, the Green Lab especially Sai,
Steven Hinshaw, Nathaniel Gray, Gerald Crabtree, Haopeng, Kevin,
Michael Green, as well as my funding sources and you all for your attention
today, and I'm happy to take any questions.
Oh, thank you for bringing me a very nice idea of the
TCIP. And I wonder whether the
opposite way of the recruitment of that BCL6 to the
p300 binding site. And
then I also think this idea can be applied to many
other transcription factors. And then also you said about the
co-activator, but you can
make a recruitment of the corepressors too.
So I want to ask you whether you guys tested the other
transcription factors and then corepressors too.
Yeah. Thank you so much for that question.
We've mostly tested in BCL6 because it's a really great model of cell
death repression. But recently, there's a preprint from another
lab targeting p53 and trying to de-repress those pathways
as well.
In terms of your question about whether BCL6 goes to p300,
we don't see signs of that.
And I think the fact that BCL6 has affinity for
DNA kind of controls the direction of that localization.
And then
can you remind me of your last question?
Corepressor.
Oh, yeah.
We haven't tried that.
But I think the idea of this gain-of-function strategy is that we're
going to get more killing
by kind of hypercharging these oncogenes
and turning on death than just recruiting a repressor.
But that's definitely something we could try. Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks for the great talk. I was just curious, how does this compound compare to
the BRD4 BCL6 heterobifunctional?
Yeah, it's a great question. They're pretty similar in terms of potency.
Some of the kinetics differ, so BRD4 does induce death a bit
faster.
The p300 one, actually, I didn't have time to talk about it, but it
rapidly represses MYC. We don't see MYC at all in proteomics.
And so there are slight differences that again, I think point to differential
effects we can get by recruiting different activators.
Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you.
And one more question. Globally, how did the p300 cistrome change?
I know you alluded to some changes, but.
Sorry, globally, can you repeat that?
The p300 cistrome like p300 chip did-
Oh, yeah. We didn't see global losses of p300. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, just a quick question to follow on with the previous question.
Do you know the percentage of p300
needed to activate BCL6? And
this crap sheet mentioned that the BRD4s only need 10%,
so.
Yeah, great question. We didn't exactly quantify p300.
We did quantify,
but from that genomic data, we saw that cell lines with only
one functional copy, so in theory, perhaps 25% or
less would be required.
Yeah.
Have you compared the RNA seqs and the signature between the
BRD4 versus p300? Anything different?
Yeah, we do. And it's
on the bio archive, but there are some key differences.
I think the biggest one that stands out is the ability of the p300 one to
repress MYC very potently. But there are some differences and
similarities as well. Mm-hmm.
Thanks.
I was wondering if you dose the compound higher, do you start to see global
loss of EP300?
We never performed the chip sequencing at higher than
one nanomolar, so.
Or even just looking globally at the histone acetylation marks on chromatin,
do you see loss of-
No, we didn't. No.
Okay. And then if you overexpress BCL6, can you actually transform this
more into a RIP-tag? Is there sort of like an incompatibility-
Yeah, that's a great question
... of the stoichiometry?
So we did that experiment with overexpression of nuclear localized
BCL6 in a cell line that according to DemMap is in
theory to hat inhibition, and we didn't see any change in sensitivity
suggesting that it's not a RIP-tag.
Yeah.
Okay, so one more round of applause. Thank you so much.
With that, we move on to our next speaker, who is Nicolas
Dicieri from Cornell, moving a little bit more into the
microenvironmental niche, looking at FGFR1
positive cancer-associated fibroblasts and the effects on
CAR T-cell efficacy.
Okay. First, I would like to thank the committee to choose our
work.
And I would start the presentation with a brief
introduction or summary of the survival landscape that are
facing the patients with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
We already know that DLBCL is one of the most common aggressive lymphoma that
exists, and the first treatment that they have is a combination of the
cocktail of chemotherapy plus anti-CD19.
We can think that they have a really
good prognosis if we compare with other kind of tumors, but because
they have a five years overall survival rate around 60 and
95%. But we are still having 40% of the
patients that are developing disease progression or relapse.
They are entering in this relapse and refractory DLBCL patient
group. Then on the second therapy, before CAR T-cells,
they were treated with another cocktail plus the autologous
stem cell transplantation. As you can see, they have the
overall survival around six months, seven months.
Then with CAR T-cells, they significantly improve the EFS
and the overall survival. But we are talking right now
also that with the failure up to 60% of the patients with this
kind of therapy. And this is the main core that
our research is focused on, trying to
find another alternative to improve the CAR T-cell therapy.
Now, the question is: Why is happening this failure?
One of the main hypothesis is also the loss of
a genetic loss function or epigenetic loss function.
And in this case, it would be CD19But we
focus more on the immunosuppressive tumor that is
established by different kinds of inflammatory chemokines,
TReg, and MDSC. In this case, we selected to
study TGF-beta because one of the main and super well-described
drivers of immunosuppressive microenvironment, because it's shutting down all the T
cell infiltration, it also drives T cell exhaustion,
and it's polarizing the macrophages to a more pro-inflammation
phenotype. So we say that's creating an immune shield.
Now, our next question was, okay, who is or which cell
is
producing the TGF-beta? So
we go back to our data that the laboratory published a few years ago.
They described the four main lymphoma microenvironments, and we found
the mesenchymal microenvironment that is enriched with
cancer-associated fibroblasts, of course, that are producing
extracellular matrix. This is another topic that we are working intensively.
But in this case also, we found they are producing
TGF-beta as well. So in this case, we know that the
main source of TGF-beta in this case would be the cancer-associated fibroblasts.
At this point, we thought, okay, we want to approach
the direct blockade of TGF-beta, but we know that it could
be tricky given all the adverse effects
related to this kind of approach. So we thought, let's go to think
about the cancer-associated fibroblasts.
And we know that cancer-associated fibroblasts are FGFR
positive, and there is a really intimate connection between
FGFR and TGF-beta.
So we took our cell lines, the fibroid reticular cells, cancer-associated
fibroblasts, and when we down-regulate the FGFR, we observed that it's a
down-regulation of transcription expression and secretion of TGF-beta.
Here to this point, we know targeting CAF, we can
down-regulate TGF-beta indirectly. Now we want to test this in vivo.
At the beginning, we used the most common cell line, the Murine,
the SET20, but also we know the SET20 is defining a kind
of depleted lymphoma microenvironment that is more
immunoresistant and also chemoresistant.
And we select an FGFR inhibitor specifically for
FGFR1. When we treat the mice, we know we observe
that it's an anti-lymphoma effect.
In this case, we need to think that we only are targeting the
fibroblasts because no lymphoma cells, no other cells have these kind of
receptors. When we check the microenvironment, we observe an increase
of three times of the macrophages.
Our question was, okay, how is this going, this
infiltration? And when we check back the down-regulation FGFR,
we observed that it not shows down-regulated TGF-beta, but also it's
up-regulating MCP, monocyte chemokine proteins.
That maybe you know as CCL2, CCL7, CCL8.
So that makes sense because we are up-regulating the cytokine, and we are
increasing the infiltration of tumor, all these macrophages.
Next question is, what are then doing these macrophages?
So we repeat experiment, but we add another arm
where we are depleting the macrophages.
And we observe there is a partial reversion of the effect inhibiting
FGFR. What that means, that these macrophages that we observe here,
they have an anti-lymphoma effect.
But it's not the only mechanism that is working all this treatment.
So in that case, we changed the model.
We went to another model
that is a cell line, but that overexpress
BCL-2 and mutation L32, GFP luciferase, and we
did intrasplenic injection in these mice.
As you can see, the cell lines, they are going to the follicles.
So we decide to study any follicle, like a tumor niche.
And then we observe,
again, infiltration of macrophages, but also an increase in
infiltration of T cells.
We approach a cellular neighborhood analysis, and
one of the most important thing that we found is if
we see the CD3 alone, that means that they are
surrounded by other CD3. There is no difference in the proliferation
in treated or not treated. But when they're in contact with
the B cells, macrophages, and all the triada,
when you hit the FGFR, increase significantly the
proliferation. What it means that
this treatment not just increase the infiltration of macrophages or T cells,
but also change in the interaction they have with each other.
So in this point what we found, okay,
they gave us the hint that could be useful for CAR T cell.
So first, thanks to Hirami Lab that provide us a PDX
that is not just relapse to R-CHOP, but also resistant to CAR T
cell. We did intrasplenic model using CAR T cell and the combination of the CAR T
cell and inhibitor FGFR.
Then we took the blood to measure how are the CAR T cells circulating and the
tumor circulating. And you can see here in the CAR T cell alone, there are
a few CAR T cells and a few other tumor cells.
Of course, in the inhibitor, only have tumor cells.
And the combination, you can see that we deplete all the tumor cells that are
circulating and
increase significantly the amount of CAR T cells that
are in circulation. Here is the quantification.
And then when we took that and we decide to go to the
spleen and check if
we can see the same.
The same result that we observe in the blood correlates perfectly as we see in the
spleen. Here you can have the CAR T cell.
It's a model resistant to CAR T cell, shows a small fraction
infiltrating the tumor, and we have a lot of tumor there.
The SSR only have the tumor, and with the combination deplete
totally, almost, the B cells, and you can see the difference between
the infiltration.So in that case,
we want to know and check the image.
And this is one of the experiments that you can see black and white, because here
in the CAR T cell, there is almost just a few cells that are infiltrated.
And when it's treated with the combination, you have all this infiltration.
Another thing is we found
an CDA exhaustion phenotype also
that
is related with the phenotype also showing
better survival with
the combination of the CAR T cells.
So
to conclude,
the EGFR
is driving an immunosuppressive microenvironment
with
producing TGF-beta, so inhibiting the infiltration of immune cells.
And when we hit the EGFR, we decrease the TGF-beta, but also we
increase the cytokines. So we are improving the infiltration of
tumor-associated macrophages and CAR T cells, and that will
open the new possibility to improve the CAR T cell
efficacy.
Yep. So I would like to thank all,
Sergedi Lab and Gidami Lab, and Webb Collaborative Medicine as the
funding. Thank you. I'm ready for questions.
Sara?
Oh, yeah. Hello. Hi. Sara Gil from Penn. Really nice work.
Thank you.
Can you tell us what you think about translational implications, how you might do
this clinically?
Yeah. When we approach
our inhibitor to specifically the patients that are
refractory to CAR T cells. So after they are not working with CAR T cells,
we can reintroduce the CAR T cell with a combination of this EGFR.
That will be... And also thinking another kind of therapy, because when we are
opening these opportunities to repress the immunosuppressive environment, we can
think, okay, other immunotherapy could be useful in that way, too.
And, so is it possible to select patients ahead of time based
on histological appearance on the lymphoma biopsy for ones where
this mechanism is more or less likely to be
at play?
Yeah, that is in our approach. We know that mesenchymal, they are
full of fibroblasts, but we are working on that, how we can
get classification of the patients.
But we now have data right now.
Thank you.
I also have one more question.
Yeah.
So could you comment on the differences in
the effects on the lymphoma cells versus the normal immune cells that
you're seeing?
Sorry, can you repeat?
So when you describe the
immunosuppressive activity of TGF-beta-
Mm-hmm.
Right.
How can you explain the differences that you see in the effects on the
lymphoma cells?
Good question. Yeah.
Of course, when we think of TGF-beta, we know how it will be affecting the
lymphoma cells. It's pretty known that lymphoma cells can have
this epigenetic adaptation to down-regulate the
SMAD, so they are kind of resistant to TGF-beta when other
cells are not. The
non-tumoral are super affected by the TGF-beta
response. Thank you.
Okay.
That's good.
Thank you very much.
With that, we can then move on to
Xujing Yang from MSK, from Michael Carosus lab,
who is going to talk about condensate dynamics that drive adaptive
METTL3 inhibitor resistance. Welcome.
Good afternoon. I hope you can see me, but I'm pretty sure you can
hear me. I'm Xujing Yang from Michael Caros Lab
at Memorial Sloan...
Thank you. Appreciate it. ... Cancer Center.
Today, I will be talking about condensate dynamic drive
adaptive METTL3 inhibitor resistance.
M6A modification is the most abundant
modification in internal MRA, and it
plays a key role on the RNA metabolism
and gene expression. It deposits dynamically by
the METTL3 continue CATE writer complex, which
METTL3 acting as the catalytic
unit.
METTL3 have been shown
in oncogenic roles in multiple cancers,
and our group and others have found that
METTL3 control in normal and malignant
hematopoiesis. In AML, METTL3
drive oncogenesis by its
methyltransferase activity to increase
more M6A modification on the oncogenic program,
such as MYC, BCL2, and P10. That enhances
its mRNA stability and also
translation.
So the STORM inhibitor is the
first-in-class potent inhibitor for
METTL3, and it shows in the
preclinical model can
strongly reduce the leukemia burden by
suppressing MYC, BCL2, and SP1
oncogenic program. For the next generation small
molecule, STC-15, that developed by the STORM
Therapeutics,
showing very encouraging safety and anti-tumor
activity in the Phase 1 study. And luckily, and
very excited, it just launched the Phase
2 trial at the past Thursday.
However-Underlying the
mechanism about sensitivity and resistance to
this inhibitor remain
unknown. So
explore what can cause the cancer
cell sensitive to METO-3 inhibitor.
We performed large scale CRISPR screening.
And using resistant cells,
pancreatic cancer cell lines and sensitive
cells, AML cells, mon13. And we
identified
103 sensitizers that can cause these
cancer cells much more sensitive to METO-3
inhibitor. And then we are focused on
the transcripts that increased in the METO-3
catalytic dead polysome profiling data
that published in 2022, narrowing down
seven top candidates. And then the strongest hit,
shockingly, is the YTERDC1 M6A
reader, that's highly suggesting a feedback
with the METO-3 inhibition.
YTERDC1 is the M6A reader that can
forms nuclear YTERDC1 M6A condensates
in AML, and products make a transcript
from the PAX RNA degradation
complex for degradation, and it requires for
AML cells survival.
We next
validate
the YTERDC1 CRISPR screening
result using in vivo melanoma and
AML in vivo model. We found that
while alone,
loss of YTERDC1 or inhibitor treatment
alone cause very minimal effect, but the
combination
strongly decrease the tumor burden and also
improve the survival.
Critically, when we overexpress YTERDC1 can cause
resistance to METO-3 inhibitor treatment and can
rescue the differentiation from the inhibitor
treated.
So after we look at the
sensitizers, we are want to explore what
behind the YTERDC1 cause resistance.
So we also have the resistant CRISPR hits.
We want to
overlap with the YTERDC1 known
interactors, and then we identify the
24 interactors that can cause
resistance in our METO-3 resistance screening.
And then we develop a high content nuclear
condensates imaging screening to detect if
these 24 hits can disturb
YTERDC1 condensates. And one of the
strongest resistance hits in our CRISPR screen is
PABPN1, and emerged as the most
significant disruptor of these condensates.
Actually, when we overexpression PABPN1, and the
number of the condensates dropping, and
these formation destroyed and also cause
resistance to METO-3 inhibition.
This is suggesting a linking
of formation of condensates to sensitivity
of the METO-3 inhibitor. When we look at the
condensates changing, METO-3 inhibition can increase the size,
the intensity, the number. However, it didn't see in the normal
CD34 cells. FRAP recovery analysis to
determine liquid-liquid phase dynamics, we found that the
bigger and the high intensity DC1 condensates show
low liquid, less like liquid, but we didn't see
it in the normal cells. This suggesting a kind of
cancer cell-specific adaptation response.
To expand our study in a very large panel of cancer
cells, we see that the
sensitive cells
that showing in blue that have a more liquid
properties of the condensates. However, the
intrinsically resistant cells showing
much low dynamic and solid-like liquid.
This suggesting that the physical properties of
the nuclear condensates that form of DC1 is
corresponds with the METO-3 inhibitor response.
From the proteomics functionally, we can found
that YTERDC1 overexpression can partially rescue the
protein changes that by METO-3 inhibition, and
which strongly enriched on the MYC related
program. We're also using the Nanopore M6A direct
sequencing and then found after METO-3 inhibition,
we still see residual M6A on the
transcripts that we
rescued here. And most importantly,
overexpression that caused the resistance sighting, we can rescue
MYC and the BCL2 protein level from the inhibitor
treatment. And when we do the MYC
overexpression is also cause resistance to METO-3
inhibition, which we identify the MYC as a key
downstream of YTERDC1 cause resistance mechanism.
We use a newly developed small molecule, very
luckily developed by our transition by all.
And with the combination with co-targeting
YTERDC1 with METO-3, we can saw very
strong synergistic effect in cancer cells,
but very minimal effect on the normal
cells.Which
suggesting a wide therapeutic window on this
combo treatment. And importantly,
when we
treat with this YTHDC1 inhibitor in the
overexpression of DC1 resistance setting, it can reverse
the resistance.
It's suggesting the
synergetic effect is working in
the
cancer setting, but spares the normal cell setting,
provide a very clinical relevant therapeutic
strategy. This is the transition bios poster.
If you interested about YTHDC1 inhibitor more, you
can go this poster section.
So because we also see the
overexpression of BCL2 that in the DC1
overexpression setting, and then we want to use a
clinical use small molecule that can improve
MITO3 inhibition in
cancer patient. So we
used venetoclax combo with MITO3 inhibition,
and we see a strong synergistic effect
in both in vitro and in vivo using
AMMPDX model. In vivo, this combo
treatment can prolonged 50
days to 85 days. Which
suggesting that bypass
YTHDC1-caused
resistance by targeting its downstream
survival program can improve MITO3
inhibition performance in cancer patients.
And this pretty clinical relevant.
In summary,
so in the sensitive cells, when we treat
with the cells with MITO3 inhibitor,
is there is a dropping of
M6A on key oncogenic
program, including MYC and BCL2, and cells
going to die and the differentiation.
However, MITO3 treatment also
induce adaptive increase of
YTHDC1, and it will form the
more gel-like or low liquid dynamic
YTHDC1 nuclear condensates. By
modulation of these properties
of DC1 condensates using YTHDC1
mutation or overexpression of PRBP1, it
can reverse the resistance to sensitive.
And these biophysical property change
and accumulation of YTHDC1 allows
YTHDC1 protein binding more to the
residue modified transcripts, including MYC and
BCL2, and rescue the translation of these
survival genes, even though with the presence of MITO3
inhibitor. Therapeutically, if we
co-targeting YTHDC1 using DC1 inhibitor,
or we use venetoclax, can restore the
sensitivity to MITO3 inhibition in cancers, and
can improve the anti-tumor responses.
So our result is highly suggesting
therapeutics strategy and to improve
MITO3 inhibitor or venetoclax
performance in cancer treatment, and it's created
a
clinically therapeutically application.
Lastly, I want to thank you Kyros lab member,
especially my mentor, Kyros,
the supportive and the hardworking with us on this
project. And also our colleagues, Emily is here, Isaac
is online, Catherine is already pursue her
PhD, very excellent. And also the amazing
collaborator lab, the Lipas lab, including
Marie Elaza about the mouse model.
And also, thank you Mason lab on the nanopore
sequencing and analysis. And we appreciate the
collaboration with Transition By All and also Storm
Therapeutics. Thank you. Happy to take any
questions.
Yeah. Thank you for this really great presentation and special
congratulations on managing presenting all these
tongue breaker
genes and pharmacology parts. So I have a question
with respect to
a possible association. Do you see any association of the
YTHDC1 protein levels
with the effectiveness basically of the inhibitor?
Yes, good question. So
we actually see the increase of
YTHDC1 protein after storm treatment,
both in vivo and in vitro. So in myeloma
in vivo and AML in vivo model, we both see
increase YTHDC1 protein after treatment.
We also have a single cell resolution
using the flow cytometry using knock
in GLP YTHDC1 cells. When we treat with the
storm, we see the increase of the GLP
DC1 protein by the flow cytometry.
And interestingly, that increase is
reversible. So when we wash out the storm, the
level of YTHDC1 go to the baseline, like
the DMSO treatment. So we think this is
the upregulation of DC1 is
a kind of cancer adapted specific thing.
And also we check the
protein, however,
we want to see if the transcriptional change on
YTHDC1. So from our qPCR result, we didn't
see the transcriptional changes on DC1.
We thought it should be a post-transcriptional or
post-translational mechanism. We're still working on it.
Thank you. Good question.
Hello.
Really good talk. And just have two questions.
So the first one is, among the seven genes that you show that
is overlapping between your resistant cells and your
sensitive cells, and why THDC1 is the top
genes that you are focusing on. Just curious, what are the other six
genes? Are they all methylation factors, or
have you guys looked into them and to see
what are they? And my second question is, if I remember correctly,
in that also slide you used that is the solid tumor,
right? The resistant line and the
sensitive line.
But your talk mostly is blood tumor.
Have you guys do any of this experiment in any solid
tumor and to see how they work?
Okay. First question is if we check other
M6A or RNA binding protein, right?
Actually, we checked of about 34,
36 M6A related reader
or modifier or eraser. Actually, in
the sensitive line, they have multiple that
comes out, including METTL3 and the
METTL13, and also DC1
comes up. And in the resistant sighting of
pancreatic cancer, so only two M6A
related genes comes up. One is DC1 and one
is METTL14. So one,
because we want to see a common sensitizer.
So when we overlap this, is DC1, this is
only one overlapped. Yeah. But however,
we more focus on the translational
upregulated transcripts. That may be the
key that cause the resistance, right?
Because you knock out, make a cell sensitize.
So
we then overlapped with the polysome data.
And then the second question is about the solid tumor.
Actually, we test the solid tumor both, including
our in vivo and the in vitro model.
We've tested both solid tumor. They are very
consistent result. For first,
treatment will cause the increase of the protein of YTHDC1,
and then
knocking out of METTL3 in the solid tumor that
resistant to METTL3 is also increased the protein level
of YTHDC1. Second, if this
intrinsically resistant to METTL3 inhibitor, they will
show very low liquid and high level of YTHDC1
protein, and is low liquid condensates.
So this all together is the solid tumor,
or leukemia is both consistent to say the
liquid dynamic nuclear condensates related to the
response.
All right. Thank you so much.
Thanks.
Can
we get in the other room? In the back one.
Ah, you have a loud voice.
I'll yell, okay?
Yeah, can hear you.
From Washington. Do you have any idea of what contribute to the
increased size and gel-like properties of the condensates and the levels
within the cells? What's in those bigger, more gel-like condensates?
Are they sequestering things that are important for the cancer?
Yeah, it's very good question. Actually-
Could you quickly repeat the question for people online? Yeah, thanks.
Okay. I repeat the question is, what is
the key components in the condensates, and
then that related to the resistant caused
by the changes of the condensates to METTL3
inhibition? This is a really good question, and we
are working very hard while trying to figure out what.
One of the data we didn't show here, and also
didn't put into our
revision publication,
submitted the publication. So this is, we did a mass
spec, and then we see some differences,
bonding changes on the resistant sighting
after METTL3 inhibition. So what
is changes is the
splicing factor was dropping
from the condensates, from the co-IP mass
spec. And then barely we gain
about what we still mystery, don't
understand what is gained in the condensates.
And then why is cause this kind of
condensates accumulation or increase?
I think it's a kind of acute feedback.
By now, my understanding about my project is
because the dropping of M6A,
they will cause a lot of RNA
can maintain, not degrade, by the DFAs in the
cytoplasm. So they will have more resources in the
condensates to forming this kind of RNA protein
interaction. That's first. And the second is,
the residual M6A still on the key
survival targets. And then the tumor cell, just very smart,
want to rescue the acute job of M6A.
So it's kind of feedback to recruit more DC1
want to bonding to the residual M6A transcripts, just
keep the MYC or BCR2 program working, and then
allow the cell survive.However,
the direct
mechanism, we are still working on it, hard working on it.
Thank you. Great question.
Okay, thank you again.
Thank you.
And with that, we move on to our next speaker, who's Dr.
Jost from the Medical University of Graz, and he's going to tell
us a story about lymphotoxin alpha.
Yeah. Thank you very much for the introduction.
It's a great honor to speak here, and I'd like to thank the
chairs to select this abstract. These are my conflicts of interest.
Now,
my lab is interested in understanding evasion of cell death in
cancer and specific leukemia cells.
We know that
different forms of programmed cell death exist, and cell
death prevents survival of tumor cells, and tumor cells, of course, try to
shut down cell death activation. We've seen in a landmark
review 25 years ago that evasion of apoptosis was
considered one of the hallmarks. And now, 25 years later, we had
the opportunity to review this in the recent review,
Cell Death in Cancer in the last 25 years, what have we developed, and
what's the clinical implication after those quarter-century
developments. So one of the pathways we are really most interested in in
leukemia is really necroptosis. It's a pathway which is
triggered in parts by activating TNF receptor
signaling and contributing to either survival or cell death,
depending on the contribution and the composition of
complex one within TNF receptor one.
And eventually, if you trigger cell death, you form a necrosome, which is a protein
complex containing proteins such as RIP
kinase one or three, caspase-8, FADD, and others.
And we've already seen 2016, a while ago, that the necrosome is
critical for tumor
suppression in leukemia using an FLT3-ITD model, where
deletion of necrosome components such as RIPK3
accelerates disease development by blocking
cell death and blocking differentiation.
So based on this, we wanted to understand what the upstream triggers for
inflammation are from the point of necrosome
activation and checked for TNF receptor ligands
using primary human AML patient sample single-cell RNA
sequencing data.
And we checked for TNF lymphotoxin alpha as a prime
ligand for TNF receptor 1 activation.
As a control, lymphotoxin beta on the right-hand side is really
binding to a different set of receptors.
Looking here at the stem cell and blast population, you can appreciate that the
cytokine expression is low to minimal for both TNF and
lymphotoxin alpha.
Whereas, the co-nate receptors indeed
present on leukemia. This is proteomics data from
primary patient samples, from 177 primary human
AML patient samples. You can see R1 and R2 are readily expressed.
R2 has a bimodal pattern, but most of the patients
express R2.
So we wanted to functionally understand that.
We generated a mouse model system, a classical FLT3-driven
myeloproliferative
model system in mice using retroviral transplantation, genetic
deleted TNF or lymphotoxin or both,
and
transplanted them into recipients deficient for those cytokines.
You can appreciate here that in the primary transplant already, loss of
lymphotoxin alone, in red, accelerates disease onset, and the
disease is fully transplantable into secondary recipients.
So it's an overt aggressive AML. And also, on the right-hand side,
colony formation shows you that the stem cell and progenitor potential of those
cells is
highly active, more than in the wild-type setting, almost approaching the
RIP kinase 3-dependent setting.
So if this is the case, then we would anticipate lymphotoxin to repress leukemia,
and that's what we tested using a range of primary human AML
bone marrow samples.
This one is one example I'm showing here.
It's a female patient with a FLT3 mutation and co-mutated
DNMT3A, PTPN11, and RUNX1.
Exposing this primary patient AML sample for seven days to
the cytokine lymphotoxin as a single agent, in this case, you can appreciate
the cell death induction is present at three and day seven to a
very potent level, and specifically within the primitive
compartment of CD34 positive, CD38 negative cells.
The remaining cells also show an interesting feature, and that is they
induce myeloid differentiation by loss of CD34 and
gain of CD38 expression by flow cytometry.
So really shifting out of the progenitor compartment into a
more mature compartment.
Indeed, this even holds true for samples which are
genetically challenging, I would say, in the sense that this is an secondary
AML from MDS patient, highly aneuploid clone, female
patient, complex karyotype, including two P53
mutations. This sample was exposed to lymphotoxin single agent, and you can
again appreciate this move from the primitive
compartment, CD34 positive and CD38 negative,
towards a more mature, more CD38 expressing mature
cellular compartment, also shown on the right-hand side in the histogram.
And importantly, also colony formation was significantly reduced.
We have less colonies, and they are smaller, just by exposing them
to the cytokine.
So we wanted to test this in vivo by using a
syngeneic,
again, FLT3-driven AML model.
This model is transplanted, and we exposed the
mice to lymphotoxin as a cytokine by
intraperitoneal injection twice a
week.And we wait for two or eight weeks until we
initiate treatment, which is important to allow for engraftment of
the leukemia. And indeed, you can see that up until
300 days, none of those animals developed any
signs of leukemia, had not to be sacrificed.
And when we sacrificed the animals which did survive until 300 days and
compared them to the mice sacrificed at the death at the vehicle
control, we can appreciate that the response in the bone marrow is
very deep. We hardly see and we essentially don't see
any GFP positive remaining cells in the bone marrow.
This was corroborated in a PDX model.
This is again one example of an FLT3-ITD mutated patient
sample with co-mutations in ASXL1 and 2,
NF1, RET21, SEK1, TED2. So it's an highly
mutated primary AML patient samples transplanted into an
immunocompromised mice,
and again exposed in this case to human lymphotoxin alpha,
and we again appreciate that until 300 days, we don't
see development of AML, whereas the wild types all
succumbed already. The vehicle succumbed.
Importantly, again,
sacrificing those mice at the end of the experiment, we see a very
potent repression of human CD45 positive cells,
spleen, blood, and bone marrow.
But what's interesting and a bit unexpected really was when we sacrificed the
mice in a syngeneic model, immunocompetent, that we can also look at the
healthy adjacent hematopoiesis within the same mice because they're GFP
negative. We can just basically flow them at the same time.
And what we did here is to check for the
cytopenia that we expected to maybe occur, which is not the case.
The mice are fully had normal blood counts, are not neutropenic, and indeed,
looking at the progenitor population just shown here,
have a robust early hematopoietic compartment, maybe even improved
above the normal healthy mice. So we
took this as an important step because we think this is an important parameter for
therapeutic window to understand what the healthy hematopoiesis
behaves like. And so we collected
64 human healthy age-matched bone marrows from healthy
donors.
Essentially, teaming up with our orthopedic surgeons that would give us
the hip replacement surgery samples,
and we collected those 64 samples.
You can see them
differentiated by differentiation stage, exposed to
lymphotoxin, and you can again see that there's
an increase and an improvement of the healthy primitive
compartment
under cytokine exposure. And one step further, we even took umbilical
cord blood healthy CD34 enriched
stem cell enriched blood samples from
three individual fresh placental collections, and
indeed could show that the cytokine exposure failed to
induce any adverse effects on this primitive compartment.
So what is the difference between the induction of cell death in
this malignant component and in not in the healthy cells?
And there's a lot of mechanistic data in the
manuscript I'd like to refer to, just give you a quick glimpse.
One is that we've seen that the composition of TNF receptor
1 is critical to define of whether healthy cells will
survive or malignant cells will die.
And one of the most important parts here, as we've seen here, is TRAF2, which is a
pro-survival adaptor protein, which is required to bring in
E3 ligases into the TNF receptor 1 complex that would
eventually cause K63-dependent
ubiquitylation of RIPK1 and also M1-linked ubiquitin,
which allows for a scaffolding platform for MAP kinase and
NF-kappa B activation. So once TRAF is depleted or deleted, you would
not get this recruitment, and cells will induce cell death.
At steady state in leukemia, driving FLT3-ITD as an oncogene,
you can see already TRAF2 depletion.
Moreover,
if you expose AML cells to LTA or TNF, you can
induce further the levels of TRAF2 which are present in those
cells. Together, basically, we're depleting the TRAF2
levels in those cells, driving them towards cell death activation.
And what about primary patient samples? What about TRAF2 levels in those samples?
So we took again 177 primary AML bone marrow
samples and used the proteomics data that were
used by Ashok Jayavelu and his peers and
group.
We compared TRAF2 levels at steady state, first
line diagnosis, compared to the FLT3-ITD
samples, and indeed, found a clear repression of TRAF2 levels in
patients. And this repression even held true for a range of
different genetic subgroups, such as NPM1 mutated, co-mutated,
and the range of other AMLs, which at least includes
117 patients. So we can say that TRAF2
levels indeed are repressed in patients and are
across the board of AML genetic subgroups, they vary a
little bit, but they seem to be overall below the level of healthy
hematopoiesis.
So we teamed up with Sicuria Therapeutics to
generate a modified cytokine based on
the motive of lymphotoxin together with a range of different
modifications on the architecture of the molecule by size
extension and using linker molecules
to allow for a stable and pharmaceutically great compound.
Two drug candidates are shown here inducing low
nanomolar efficacy in killing a TRAF2 knockout reporter cell
line. On the right-hand side, you can see a P53 mutated
AML cell line, again, using our two compounds,
certainly better than the standard of care, which would be
revumimab as a main inhibitor in MLL translocation or
venetoclax as a standard of care in frail elderly
AML.So this suggested that we can
test those compounds and also in primary patient samples. That's what we did.
This is one example here of an adverse risk
for a male patient with a complex cytogenetics and a range of
different genetic mutations. Exposing this patient
to the drug candidates indeed shifts the CD34
positive compartment up towards more mature.
It reduces cell death and together is a powerful drug candidate, which
we then tested in a PDX model as shown here.
Again, I'd like to refer to this complex
cytogenetics including a monosomy seven, which would be clinically a challenging
situation. This sample was transplanted
into
immunosuppressed mice. We waited until the bone marrow engraftment
rate was 20% before we started treatment.
And after 42 days, you can see that both drug candidates indeed
essentially eradicate the leukemia in the bone marrow.
So to summarize,
this is basically the concept that we are
seeing here, that lymphotoxin binds the TNF receptor 1.
This causes the recruitment of TRAF2 to the cytoplasmic tail,
and we have a co-activation of TNFR2, which is driven
by membrane-bound TNF as a consequence of the remaining NF-kappa B
activation, causing a co-recruitment of the remaining TRAF2 to
TNFR2. This causes in competitive recruitment within the
cells, and eventual degradation, downregulation of
TRAF2, driving cell death activation.
And this cell death is in part IL-1B
releasing, causing an IL-1 receptor-dependent differentiation program,
basically a dual mechanism of action, what we had seen some years ago
already. And together, we think that it can be a very powerful tool
to repress AML samples, even in the presence of
P53 mutations. I'd like to thank
the team of my lab and Michael Dengler's lab,
who run really in a clinical department, those
questions on a
technologically high level, and Michael and Cheyenne have been
instrumental here in driving this project forward.
I'd like to thank the teams that have helped us in bringing this to fruition and
also our funding agency in Cycuria for developing
this further. Thank you very much.
Hi. That was really nice and interesting work.
I don't think I quite understood the differentiation.
How do you think that happens?
So
some 10 years ago, this concept of emergency granulopoiesis
was coined when Markus Manns has shown that essentially the
stem and progenitor compartment in a healthy setting can sense cytokines
and respond to cytokine exposure by a
granulopoiesis, and a rapid shift into driving
differentiation and also output of granulocytes.
And I think this is happening here as well.
I think that the stem cell compartment in the malignant setting still has the
capability of sensing LTA or cytokines,
such as LTA, as an antigen, as a cytokine,
it would drive this proliferative program
towards a granulopoiesis, and therefore it matures out,
and the cell
loses its stem and progenitor capacity.
So this is a different sort of mechanism to the one
that we think of with respect to,
in some cases, targeting oncogenes like KMT2A
or
in some cases-
Yeah
... even FLT3 inhibition or IDH inhibition.
It is a transcriptional program, but only by a
physiologically normal upstream NF-kappa B activation, I would...
Okay. Thank you.
So how far away do you think from a timeline are you,
or are we from using this in patients?
That's a good question. Of course, we are basically at the moment, at a
situation that we
are close to an--
We've got the data needs to be recapitulated in
larger PDX cohorts.
We need GMP
generation of the compound, and then eventually,
the company would need to make an IND filing to make this next step, basically.
We're not far away. I think we are,
but of course, further additional support will be needed to bring this to fruition.
So what's the mechanism of TRAF2
reduction,
and would a TRAF2
degrader be
another idea- Yeah ... to use for treatment? So that's a very good point.
So the point is that we see this degradation.
I think it's a very physiologically normal degradation of TRAF2 in the context of a
negative feedback within
the complex one.
And we've thought about using a TRAF2 degrader in the context of just basically
using something that would cause destruction of the complex, but it
wouldn't probably be different than a CIP1 or CIP2 inhibitor.
They would also do the same thing, and they haven't shown the same efficacy.
So what I think is really needed, and it's in the manuscript in a bit more detail,
we do need a TNFR1 activator to induce a
death signal. So just by depleting or
destroying complex one alone, you might not get sufficient of a
clustering and activation of TNF receptor one complexes that
would allow for an actual death signal.
So in that sense, I think the extracellular one is much better to induce a
death signal and deplete the TRAF2 receptor because if we use a
TNFR2 ligand,
we can also deplete TRAF2, but we don't get a death signal, and then the whole
thing doesn't work anymore.
Great. Thank you so much.
Well doneWe are moving on to our final
speaker of this session, which is Matteo Brindisi,
who's going to talk to us about MET12L as a
possible novel player in platelet dysfunction in myeloid neoplasms.
Welcome.
Hello, everyone. Thank you for the kind introduction and of course, for
giving me the opportunity to be here and present our findings.
So this is my disclosure. Our main topic is
myeloid neoplasms that are representing an
heterogeneous group of bone marrow malignancies arising from
clonal and genetic alteration of the hematopoietic stem cells,
leading to impaired self-renewal and dysfunctional
maturation, and consequently altered production of measured blood
cells.
So in the last decades, the mediator
complex, composed by up to 30 proteins and
particularly the presence of MET12 in the mediator
complex, has been linked to the transcriptional promotion of
many genes required for HSCs maintenance and
functionality. So following that, we are
focused on
a paralog of MET12 that is called MET12L
that is a tidark gene. So MET12 caught our
attention based on its typical expression,
on the hematopoietic hierarchy. In fact, microarray
data from human and also mouse samples,
revealed that the MET12L expression is
higher at the level of the hematopoietic stem cells and
decreases along their maturation path, and increase again at
the level of the megakaryocyte precursors.
So, this pattern led us
to hypothesize that the context-dependent presence
of this MET12L in the mediator complex could
be associated with megakaryocyte priming.
But this is in line with the data from
our collaborator that clearly showed that in two
different
NPN mouse model
malignancies that is characterized by the overproduction of
platelets and/or red blood cells, the MET12L
resulted upregulated in relevant progenitors.
And conversely, in a different mouse model
in which the NPN was normalized by the
deletion of PBX1 that was generated in our
laboratory, the MET12L resulted downregulated.
So
this led us to hypothesize that the context-dependent presence
of MET12L could be associated with megakaryocyte
priming and also myeloid skewing that are both altered in
myeloproliferative neoplasms. So taking advantage of the
MET12L knockout mice model that was generated by The Jackson
Laboratory, we began investigating the physiological function of
MET12L in HSPCs and in peripheral blood, gaining
insights on its potential involvement in myeloid neoplasms.
So,
we plan to monitor the peripheral blood of MET12L knockout mice
longitudinally, start at six weeks of age up to
24 weeks. But today I'll show you the results obtained at 12 weeks,
but similar results were also obtained at the other time points.
So
peripheral blood analysis showed stable platelets count
and increase in the mean platelets volume in the knockout
with respect to wild type. So this higher dimension
were also confirmed by blood smears analyzed by
QPAT. So while no changes in the other
blood lineages were detected. So
to deeply study the platelets compartment, we
decide to
work on platelet-rich plasma. And the FACS analysis clearly
showed that the knockout platelets display
higher dimension,
together with increased internal complexity and higher
expression of CD41 and CD61 integrins on the
surface of
the knockout platelets with respect to wild type.
So the higher dimension and also the increased internal
complexity led us to hypothesize defects in their maturation
path.
So, based on that, we
decide to assess the
contents of nucleic acid as the RNA content
reflects platelets maturity.
And as you can appreciate, the knockout platelets display a higher
Thioflavin orange signal, reflecting higher percentage
of reticulated platelets in the knockout with respect to wild type.
So we also confirmed this finding with a different
approach. So through the transmission electron microscopy, we observed that
the knockout platelets display a higher endoplasmic reticulum
content that is marked with a triangle red in the images in their cytoplasm.
So confirming that MET12L loss could affect
platelets maturity.
So
in order to study better the platelet compartment,
we
decide to challenge this compartment.
And we did
this through the administration of a specific
antibody that cause thrombocytopenia via platelet
aggregation in the mice. So we injected intraperitoneally the
H300 antibody, and then we monitored daily the
peripheral blood. And as you can appreciate, we observed
a kinetics production of
platelets that was delayed in the knockouts with respect to wild
type. SoAfter two weeks of treatment,
we decide to
sacrifice the mice to have the opportunity to take a look at the bone marrow, and
specifically to the main population leading to platelets
production. And as you can appreciate, we did not observe any
changes in the HSCs frequency and also in the
megakaryocytes between wild type and knockout, but we
observed a slight increase in the knockouts
regarding the frequency of megakaryocyte precursor.
But interestingly, we observed a higher percentage
of HSCs expressing, so primed to platelets
production,
based on the higher expression of CD41
at this level. And we also observed the increase the CD41
and CD61 integrins on the surface of the megakaryocyte,
as we also observed at platelets level in periphery in the knockout with
respect to wild type. So
however, this observation did not allow us to distinguish
if these effects are mediated by the
direct absence of METTL14L
just in the hematopoietic compartment or in the microenvironment.
So to address this question, we
did the transplantation experiment.
So,
we lethally irradiated our CD45.1
BL6 recipient mice, and then we transplanted them with either wild
type or
METTL14L knockout bone marrow cells.
And after eight weeks,
we
checked the engraftment, and as you can appreciate from the graph, all the
peripheral blood cells are donor
derived, and only about
4% are
derived from recipient and is represented by the
CD3 from the recipient. So in this model,
we checked the platelets compartment, and
interestingly, we found that the phenotype that we are described
is also preserved even
in wild type recipient mice. So we confirmed that the
effects that we described that platelets compartment are
cell autonomous.
In this model, we also deeply characterize the
platelets compartment. And as you can appreciate, we observed that the
knockout platelets are more
prone to be cleared, as indicated by the
higher glycosylation states and
reflecting higher percentage of
platelets positive to ACL. So we
confirm these findings also with a biotinylation assay that we use
to
dye all the peripheral blood cells,
in particular way the platelets, and then we monitor
it daily their clearance over time.
So, and as you can appreciate, the half-life of knockout
platelets was dramatically reduced in the
knockouts with respect to wild type, suggesting that
METTL14L loss
affects platelets compartment.
So of course, the main aim of this project is to assess
whether METTL14L could play a
role in MPN.
And to address this question, we generated a new mouse model
that carry both the JAK2 mutation, that is the
driver mutation that is
present in the vast majority of MPN cases, and the deletion
of METTL14L, so generating the JM mice.
So we then subject the JM wild type and JAK2
mice to poly I·poly C regimen in order to induce the
JAK2 V617F mutation and to induce
the disease. And as you can see,
we successfully induce the MPN phenotype, as you
can appreciate by increased red blood cells and also platelets production
in the MPN mice with respect to the
wild type. And interestingly, what we observed is that
the deletion of METTL14L in the JM
mice was
sufficient to counteract thrombocytosis,
in this model, while having no effects on the erythrocytosis.
So, this evidence confirmed
that the loss of METTL14L affects platelets compartment,
but also in the MPN mice model, but is
relevant to counteract the thrombocytosis that these are typical
MPN features.
So, but what about patients? That, of course, is our ultimate
goal. And,
so
to address this question, we analyzed the single-cell RNA-seq data
from peripheral blood of MPN patients.
And as you can see, the analysis revealed that
the MPN patients
present the higher percentage of
platelets that express METTL14L, and this
expression correlates strongly with platelets features.
And on the other hand, we also confirmed this link in
MDS cohort. So
clinical and RNA-seq data from MDS
patients clearly show that the expression of
METTL14L correlates with platelets count and also with platelets
features. So
concluding, I just want to summarize the main take home message of this
presentation. So we observed that the deletion of
METTL14L clearly impact on platelets
compartment,
determining the production of platelets with
altered
dimension and also maturation states.
And,We observed a
kinetics altered in terms of production, but
also clearance. And we also confirmed that the
effects that we ascribed to MET12L is
cell autonomous. And interestingly, the absence of
MET12L is able to counteract thrombocytosis
directly in MPN mouse models, so suggesting
that this absence could affect thrombocytosis,
so could be interesting in the managing of these
malignancies. And also, we
confirmed the link between
MET12L and
MPN and MDS directly in patients, so
pointing out a potential role for this gene in
the managing of these malignancies.
So I'm going to conclude just to acknowledging all the
people that are helping me through the development of this project,
particularly my PI, Francesca Ficara and
Matteo Della Porta, and of course, all the external and
internal collaborators, and of course, all of you for your kind attention.
And I'm happy to take all of your questions. Thank you.
I can also start with one. That was fantastic talk, very
thought-provoking. Do you think the MET12L,
is the effect more on the progenitor cells or on
the mature megakaryocyte? Do you know?
Yeah, it's an interesting question.
So
I didn't show some results, but we
studied also the progenitors,
and also the fitness of the HSCs. And we did not
observe any changes in the regenerative capacity of HSCs at the still
state. And also, of course,
after the treatment with the antibody, R300.
So we are now plan to do the single-cell
RNA seq
on the bone marrow just to
check whether the absence of MET12L could
affect the maturation. So in my opinion,
and based on the data that we are collected
till now, of course,
I think that the absence of MET12L could affect the
last part of maturation. So from the megakaryocyte to
the
proplatelets formation, then platelets.
So we are working also with some collaborator in
Italy that
made the 3D scaffold of the bone marrow.
So we are
waiting about the results, but yeah, we are working on that. Yeah, thank you.
Yeah. Thank you for the nice lecture.
And I wanted to ask whether the
MET12L has the
correlation with the blood clotting.
Okay. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's an interesting question. So at the moment, we did some
experiments about the activation of platelets.
So
we did not see any changes between wild type and
knockout after
normal stimuli like ADP and thrombin in terms
of P-selectin expression, for example.
But of course, as I said at the beginning, so
in the knockouts, there is a higher expression of CD41 and
CD61 in the grains. So of course, we
think that these platelets are more prone to,
not to be activated, but to aggregate.
Mm-hmm.
And in fact, based on that, we are planning to do some experiments
about aggregation.
So is there any GWAS correlation of any
type of anemia to the MET12L?
To the anemia?
Hmm. I'm not sure. But of course, there is a link between
MET12L and AML. So
I knew that there is some paper that is...
So the expression of MET12L correlates poorly with the
prognosis of the AML patients. So in fact, we are also
studying the MDS, and we found that
the expression of MET12L in the progenitors could
affect the maturation, so also the formation, maybe the
leukemia stem cells. So
yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
We managed to be
exactly three minutes over time, so we filled the session.
I would just really like, on behalf of Rong and
myself, thank all the speakers. It was really cutting-edge,
cutting and hitting so many different areas in
hematology.
And all of you for coming. And I think it would be great
if the speakers would have a little bit of time to stay in case there are any more
questions, more discussions in here.
But wishing everybody a good afternoon
and an exciting rest of the meeting.
All right. Okay.
We did it.
Great session.
It was. And it's awesome. Two hours is long.